shall season
uh utah hey chelsea what's up um
so i just have a question uh so
i'm in baby step two but i just had this
like
aha moment where i know what i want to
do with my life
and i i found that i want to start a
business
organizing home but in order to do it
[Music]
legally uh i'm gonna have to put some
money into it which is
it's it's not gonna be any more than
five thousand dollars
oh it does not take five thousand
dollars to start a home organizing
business
well i have to get like licenses and
like
oh you don't you're in classes and
whatever you have to take a class on
organizing
you are already an organized person
look up organizing on youtube and watch
it for five hours
you will have become the most most
educated
organizer on the planet and then just
hand out some cards and go to people's
houses and take their money for that
you don't even need to get licensed this
it's not illegal to operate a
single person service oriented business
where you go to someone's home out of
your home
on a small scale in any municipality
you have you've built this up to be way
bigger than it is just go do some work
make some money
okay how much you're gonna charge uh
i was thinking probably like
100 to 200 per room where'd you get that
number
um out of my butt
[Laughter]
well uh probably i'll do some more
research
than that
oh lord of mercy i'm losing it
oh i'll take over yeah yeah please pick
up talking
i was gonna say home organizing it is
like a fad right now there's a lot of
instagram accounts there's a lot of
people doing it a lot of people doing it
so
you will you will be able you will
you will be able to do it well and then
and and then ask around from different
competition around to see what they
literally are trying
to go online and start doing some
research for organ home organizers in
your area
and try to find out what they're
charging and so what you do is you study
competition in your
area and and people that are doing it in
similar size cities across america
you can do all of that with some simple
google searches
and um then you'll figure out that it's
ten dollars a room
and not a hundred dollars a room or
you'll figure out that they don't charge
by the room they charge by the house or
by the hour
or something else so you look at
different pricing models and different
ways to pull this together
and you lay that out and
you pull oh y'all
if i could just close my eyes i could
keep talking um it's got to be a full
moon or something
so yeah it's called in business when
you're looking for
you look for successful people and uh
you copy their ideas we call it best
practices
and so if we're launching a marketing
campaign or a pricing structure or a
business model around here we try to
find someone
who's been successful in that space
before and we emulate or
model or copy them after that
so hey thanks for the call this is the
dave ramsey show
you